all right he is a non-resident fellow
that's the way to be there at the modern
moore institute at west point and host
of max brooks breaks down on youtube max
brooks
and she is a poster and founding partner
at echelon insights our returning
champion kristen soltis anderson is back
with us here on real time
okay so as i was talking to the
secretary i
got a lot of anxiety because i keep
hearing nuclear war i keep hearing world
war three
which uh we tried to book someone on the
panel uh who had experience with world
war iii but it hasn't happened yet so we
don't but max wrote world war z
so that's why you're here and also
we're in trouble the russian army has
been fighting like zombies uh yeah so
but i know you were uh watching our show
last week and you heard me say why
didn't
putin
invade ukraine when his boyfriend trump
was in office i mean
trump stood with him at helsinki
and defended him over our own
intelligence agencies so i was just
asking the question
and maybe you do have an answer
why not
when trump was in office it would seem
to be the more logical place no he
didn't invade because he didn't need to
because you only roll out the tanks when
you think you're out of options and
putin had a grand asymmetric strategy to
dismantle nato from within and it was
working when the commander-in-chief of
the united states armed forces calls
nato obsolete you are on the road to a
fifth column victory and that's what he
was doing and as a matter of fact we
know now in 2018
well
we know this in 2018 trump wanted to
pull out of nato and it was john kelly
and john bolton who had to hold him down
like a rabid dog to stop him from doing
that and if trump had won a second term
he would have done it but biden being
elected caused his plan to go up in
smoke we don't know what he would have
done we don't know why he did what he
did
you